eddie wu is a mathematics teacher on a
mission the once viral youtuber now
leads a government program designed to
transform the maths performance of
schools producer even hunger headed to
one regional high school where there's
been a miraculous maths turnaround
[Music]
well google has been without an
extension to class for about seven years
there was kind of this view in students
that
we are just will google high school we
aren't
someone special we're not
sitting in sydney with lots of resources
in this private school or anything like
that when really none of that is true we
can achieve to a really high standard
[Music]
the mathematics growth team program is
about identifying fantastic teachers who
have expertise and knowledge to share so
our trainers come into the school to
work shoulder to shoulder with teachers
to support them with implementing those
ideas each day in the
we're
classroom
a beautiful regional area on the mid
north coast of new south wales and i'm
just really looking forward to working
with the mathematics teachers here
and i divided by three
then i divided by two
in the almost 10 years now that i've
been putting my own classroom lessons up
on youtube and it's crazy to think that
it's been that long i've learned a few
lessons about what my own teaching
or what characteristics of my own
teaching really resonate with people
[Applause]
number one i don't think that solves the
problem number two i think it kind of
flies a bit in the face of what they're
trying interest matters but that's not
the only thing
success is probably the most important
thing that i want my students to feel
so for teachers we would say the kinds
of tasks or activities that we give to
students we want them to have a low
floor
and a high ceiling you might not need a
lot of prior knowledge to start off with
but the task itself actually has a lot
of sophistication and depth hidden
inside
i'm a trainer with the mathematics
growth team i was trying to transition
the faculty away from the very
traditional style
of teaching
and
increase instead the at the expectations
of what our students can achieve
yeah so what are we proving previews in
the sandwich there on that one is less
than or equal one is less than or equal
to a half
so i started to
feed them bits and pieces from either
outside the syllabus or from advanced
years in the syllabus you know nine year
nine year ten
to sort of get a feel for
one could they do it no matter what i
gave them they were like yeah we'll have
a go at that and then
we started to expand them into
let's do some fun applications of
mathematics so the problem we set them
was how many marshmallows can you fit in
a teenage boy so there's your basic
calculation stuff and a marshmallow or
three or four because you have to eat a
couple to test them actually they're
good of course and it's part of the joy
the experiment
and then they have to communicate that
they had to produce a little report so
they're then being able to say i can do
the maths but i can then communicate
what that mathematics means
here we want three lots of things i took
a little bit of a double take when we
had extension two students
yeah
i just
kind of ran along with them like this is
awesome
[Music]
i graduated with high school at the end
of last year in 2021
my perspective changed on my sort of
level of math towards the end of high
school where i was getting pushed by my
teachers at that time i was sort of
thinking about extension 2. so i think
we all just went in there like okay miss
winter
basically our school mum was telling us
to do this we better do this
it didn't take very much convincing it
was just kind of like phoenix you can do
this you know you can do this and for
where you want to go after school this
will be really supportive
for you regardless of what result you
actually get
sitting the exam alone was really tough
so it was basically myself and five
supervisors
once i had finished the exam and walked
out of the hall basically it felt like a
ton of bricks had just fallen off my
shoulders it was
it was a big deep breath in like i had
finally finished the hardest math i
could do in year 12.
i can basically do anything
[Music]
currently i'm studying
a bachelor of cyber security and
computing
with the australian defense force
academy here in canberra and i think
yeah there was a massive cultural
difference between when i when i started
at wilbur high school and when i
finished
we've gone from having no students in
extension two last year we had two
students take extension to this year
we've got 19.
i was thinking that was super hard
that's why
i wasn't really going to do it
but then the school all of serious
encouragement really encouraged us to
push ourselves and that's we ended up
doing it
i'm evaluating from six and a half to
six hundred me the same thing minus the
same thing so equals zero spot on
he does more than just teach the subject
he really engages with it and engages us
with it what's missing from that
integral
bounds what are the bounds
in which order what goes at the bottom
one right it always goes
smallest to biggest straight up right
it's fantastic to see like
we will google high school have a
massive extension to class take care
everyone bye bye
[Music]
well google high school's on hogwarts
we're not offering quidditch matches and
sumptuous feasts of high calorie food
it's a regional high school and what
we're doing here could be done at any
school you care to name i would think
that's the program for tonight thanks
for your company good night